ambiance particulière cette année sur le
tour de france 2020 au départ de la 21e
et dernière étape à mantes-la-jolie
masque obligatoire pour les coureurs
journalistes à distance des cyclistes
pour les interviews un village de départ
clairsemée du gel hydroalcoolique
distribués mais les passionnés ont fait
abstraction de cet environnement pour
profiter de l'événement on avait été
frustré de pas avoir de vélo pendant la
période du gros navires us deux racks et
du gouvenement donc un grand plaisir
tant plaisir de voir l événement comme
ça je le voulais cette année l événement
un beau symbole pour nous d'être ici
aujourd'hui on puise sa c les journées
du patrimoine et le tour de france fait
partie de l'histoire de la france
un contexte particulier qui n'a pas
refroidi l'ambiance sur la caravane
[Musique]
ici la centaine de caravanes est faite
cette dernière étape dans la bonne
humeur des défis sont également au
programme
cette célèbre marque de café réunit deux
clubs cyclistes locaux
l'entente cycliste vernouillet verneuil
et riel et l'entente cycliste du goût
d'année les équipes se mettent chacune
se m trainer et ils vont s'affronter du
coup pendant 40 minutes et doivent
parcourir le plus de kilomètres possible
quatre membres de chaque équipe
s'affrontent sur ce relais virtuel est
connecté
c'est marrant cuilleron j'ai un petit
peu de un petit peu un petit challenge
quand même c'est finalement le club de
houdan qui a remporté la victoire une
cinquantaine de mètres plus loin on
retrouve le plus gros contingent de
cette caravane du tour de france 2000
vingt sept grandes surfaces possède onze
véhicules sur les 100 présents cette
année sur l'événement malgré la crise
sanitaire
c'est particulièrement important cette
année dans la mesure où les français
avaient envie de faire la fête de
retrouver des événements sportifs
d'ampleur et le tour de france est
historiquement l'événement sportif
français qui rassemble au bord des
routes chaque année et même en septembre
et même malgré les conditions sanitaires
c'était important pour nous d'être
présent pendant ces trois semaines cette
caravane accompagner ce tour de france à
distance sans contact avec les coureurs
une frustration pour thierry fabre
pompiers à saint léger en yvelines qui a
accompagné ce tour de l'intérieur sur le
véhicule des sapeurs pompiers pour le
coc vides il y avait une bulle course on
n'avait pas le droit d'aller voir les
coureurs mon shoot une fois alors chers
merlette on a pu les chiots dans les
derniers 300 m vu qu'on ne pouvait pas
descendre avec la caravane du tour
chez les seuls moments où on a pu
regarder et prendre du plaisir
le public a lui pu voir les coureurs et
les stars de ce tour de france pendant
cette journée à mantes la jolie et
notamment le vainqueur de cette édition
le slovène de 21 ans tu as des jo paugam
chars une fois les présentations
terminées les cyclistes sont partis du
côté du quartier du val fourré
c'est un événement exceptionnel parce
que c'est l'événement le plus populaire
qu'on puisse imaginer
l'accès est gratuit les cyclistes sont
des sportifs qui nous semble accessible
c'est des moments inoubliables pour les
habitants ont signé ça ça méritait qu'on
se mobilise pour et et c'est inoubliable
pour nous mêmes élus rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle étape dans
les yvelines le département est
partenaire du tour de france au minimum
jusqu'en 2023